this was a concept that was happening in
another country in Europe and my
co-founder saw the idea brought it to me
we could find it back in the US and we
completely transformed that idea we
executed much much better than did they
did we rebranded it we used Applied
Technology in novel ways and we changed
say the operations we really really
changed it but it wasn't even our idea
it wasn't our us who thought it up we
thought of how to use technology in a
brilliant way but it was a concept that
was elsewhere and I've been I do a lot
of traveling and there are so many
fabulous things happening other
countries and I think why aren't we
doing that here
a lot of my inspiration as I was
building sub car or these other
companies has been that I tried to read
and follow people and Twitter and go to
lectures that are outside of my area of
expertise because then you are like
thinking wow like that's a really cool
idea what if we took that and put that
here but you have to have that type of
input coming from all these different
areas so it's makes it's not like I'm
trying to have new connections but when
you're hearing new things it's making
you think and look at things differently
than everyone else has done I think you
can be an entrepreneur at any age and I
the Kauffman Foundation did this study
and even as I say these words it's
unbelievable to me but their study was
really robust the average age of
startups is of a start-up entrepreneur
is 49 it is not people in their 20s so a
I feel like we're in this kind of
imagining that everyone starts right out
of college not necessarily the case the
nice piece of starting out of school is
can you live at home and not have anyone
and not have to carry your food and
living expenses that's ideal if you
can't do that can you be married and
have your spouse pay for the expenses
that would be that's also ideal
Minimum Viable Product is what is the
least smallest thing that you can start
with that you can start having customers
with and start learning about what it is
that you want to do because I talked
before about being a learning company
you want to really iterate fast and if
we think of the difference one of the
differences between big companies and
small companies is that in a small
company you can turn on a dime like you
know in half an hour you can make a
decision and act on it where isn't a big
company it will take months many levels
of decision making to make any changes
so that's how small companies can
actually compete because they are
iterating so incredibly fast so you want
to start with the Minimum Viable Product
and then you can really follow the path
that's interesting to your client base
because you are following the clients as
you move up it is important to get as
close to your customers as fast as
possible and I find even with myself
that it's really hard to do a Minimum
Viable Product this minimum that you're
constantly thinking no no it really has
to have this other partner really has to
have this and then you over build and
then you have to unbilled and D build
which is very disappointing so doing a
Minimum Viable Product is really
important and it's even more minimum
than you think it is